how the hell did you go about just
managing your day at the height of
things maybe compared to when you were
just like maybe a bit more all over the
place and like what did your day plan
look like on that when you're like 16
and six and a half yeah a week it's a
really good question i'd love to have a
really good answer just give us what
yeah just what a typical day would look
like yeah absolutely i i guess at that
point is probably very resourcing heavy
okay because we kind of had like we got
to a point where we'd won the clients we
needed some wins yeah yeah so it's very
much just a hundred miles an hour trying
to kind of like fill the jobs there was
a lot of kind of meetings with clients
discussing like right like this demand
or like this project coming out i guess
at my peak of billy was the time i'd
like the biggest team from a management
perspective okay so
2021 is when i have my kind of best book
but that's when we kind of grew the team
and i was managing the most people so a
lot of i guess was like checking in with
the team making sure that everyone had
how did you manage that with all that
that's what a lot of people struggle
with yeah did you set boundaries with a
team did you like like how did you go
about making sure like all your time
didn't get obviously it should hopefully
benefit you and everyone else involved
yeah long term but you're responsible
that and like you said you clearly take
your reputation seriously how did you
manage that whilst also growing and
managing the team timewise i want to say
like lucky but i guess we've done it
like time and time again but
whenever we interview people we try and
get people on like the upward trajectory
of their careers yeah yeah and it's
quite hard to like know who is like an
sr2 person quite hard to kind of like
define it but i think we've done a
really good job of hiring people most of
them have been experienced yeah but that
are like motivated that once do well and
they're like kind of good humans they've
got kind of like good values and stuff
so i think hiring people have got
experience putting them into this
environment kind of showing them what's
possible showing them standard like yeah
but getting them to become like an
industry specialist and then i guess
like kind of delegating responsibility
to people and empowering them and
obviously
if you're getting them on that upward
trajectory they probably value autonomy
quite a lot don't they yeah absolutely
and they're super motivated they want to
do well but i think we just kept like
delegating and empowering people and
giving them responsibility so it's not
about me at all it's about everyone else
and everyone else is kind of like manage
their own stuff and also check in and
kind of help and sitting on calls and
meetings and stuff but you kind of want
to get to a point whereby you almost
don't need to be there and the team's
like actually kind of managing itself
and if someone's having a tricky call
someone's going to jump in and be like
actually this how we do things or this
we should do this
[Music]